SPREAD TOO FAR APART, ARE THEY?
THEY ARE ALLOWED TO.
THEY WON’T REPORT THEMSELVES.
HELLO, STEVE.
OKAY, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I’M HONORED TO BE JOINED BY
REPRESENTATIVES OF MANY GREAT
AMERICAN RETAIL COMPANIES, SOME
OF THE GREATEST COMPANIES
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD.
AND WE ARE TALKING TODAY ABOUT
DIFFERENT THINGS INCLUDING
DISTRIBUTION AND MEDICAL
DIAGNOSTICS, ET CETERA.
YOU WILL SEE IN A SECOND THEY
WILL SAY HELLO.
AND IF YOU JOINED ME IN THE ROSE
GARDEN TO LAUNCH A NEW
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE PRIVATE
SECTOR TO DRAMATICALLY INCREASE
AND ACCELERATE AMERICA’S
CAPACITY TO TEST FOR THE
CORONAVIRUS.
WE’VE MADE SUCH STRIDES LIKE IT
WOULDN’T EVEN BE -- YOU WOULDN’T
BELIEVE IT.
WE HAD A CALL WITH THE
GOVERNORS.
I GUESS THEY WERE JUST ABOUT ALL
ON THE CALL.
EVERYBODY WAS VERY HAPPY AND THE
TESTING IS GOING REALLY WELL.
WE ARE DOING MORE THAN ANYBODY
ELSE.
PROBABLY SOME OF YOU WERE ON THE
CALL EVEN THOUGH YOU AREN’T
SUPPOSED TO BE.
THE TESTING ITSELF IS GOING VERY
WELL.
NO COMPLAINTS.
SINCE THEN, WHAT WE’VE ACHIEVED
IS NOTHING SHORT OF AMAZING.
UNITED STATES HOLDS THE RECORD
FOR TESTING.
WE HAVE CONDUCTED MORE THAN
5.4 MILLION TESTS, MORE THAN ANY
OTHER COUNTRY ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD.
THEY ARE ACTUALLY GROWING AT A
VERY RAPIDLY.
YOU PROBABLY HEARD THOSE NUMBERS
JUST CAME OUT AFTER ENCOURAGING
GOVERNORS DECEMBER UNUSED
TESTING CAPACITY AND THEIR
STATES.
LAST WEEK PROVIDED CONTACT
INFORMATION FOR SPECIFIC LABS
WHERE THEY COULD FIND ADDITIONAL
TESTING AND CAPACITY.
WITHIN 48 HOURS, THE NUMBER OF
TESTS PERFORMED BEGAN TO
SKYROCKET.
EARLY IN APRIL, THE
UNITED STATES AVERAGED
PROXIMALLY 150,000 TESTS PER DAY
DAY.
THAT’S NOT VERY SUBSTANTIALLY
FROM A COUPLE OF WEEKS BEFORE.
AND THE 150,000 A DAY HAS GONE
TO WEIGH OVER 200,000 TESTS PER
DAY SINCE WEDNESDAY.
THIS INCLUDES A 122% TESTING
INCREASE IN MICHIGAN AND IN
MARYLAND AND MANY OTHER
LOCATIONS IN THAT FACILITY.
SOME ARE HIGHER.
TO PROVIDE FURTHER GUIDANCE,
TODAY WE ARE RELEASING OUR
BLUEPRINT FOR STATE TESTING
PLANS AND RAPID RESPONSE
PROGRAMS.
TOGETHER, WE ARE ACCELERATING
TESTING FOR AMERICANS AT RETAIL
LOCATIONS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
ESPECIALLY IN OUR
AFRICAN-AMERICAN AND HISPANIC
COMMUNITIES, WE ARE GOING VERY
STRONG IN THOSE COMMUNITIES.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY 73 RETAIL
TESTING SITES AND 25 STATES.
IN THOSE SPECIFIC AREAS.
WE ARE INCREASING IT VERY
SUBSTANTIALLY.
A LOT OF PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE
FOR AFRICAN-AMERICAN TESTING,
HISPANIC-AMERICAN TESTING AND
ASIAN-AMERICAN.
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
FROM EACH OF THESE INCREDIBLE
BUSINESS PEOPLE WHO WORK SO
STRONGLY WITH US RIGHT FROM THE
BEGINNING.
IT WAS ONLY 45 DAYS AGO THAT WE
GOT TOGETHER AND SO MUCH
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE.
I THOUGHT MAYBE WE WOULD GO
AROUND THE ROOM AND SAY JUST A
COUPLE OF WORDS.
WE ARE HAVING A NEWS CONFERENCE
IN THE ROSE GARDEN, BECAUSE A
LOT OF THESE FOLKS WILL BE
JOINING US.
THEY’VE GOT A BIG GIFT TO OUR
NATION AND TO THE PEOPLE FROM
SOME OF THE COMPANIES.
I APPRECIATE IT.
WE WILL START OFF WITH A VERY
SMALL COMPANY, A VERY SMALL
LITTLE RETAILING COMPANY KNOWN
AS WALMART HEADED BY ED GREAT
GUY.
>> STEVE --
>> RICHARD, WALGREENS.
>> MARK ESPER, SCIENTIFIC.
>> KROGER.
>> U.S. COTTON.
>> RIGHT AID.
>> President Trump: OKAY, WE
HAVE THIS GENTLEMAN.
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS IS MADE AND
WE WILL BE TALKING TO YOU IN A
LITTLE WHILE OUT OF THE NEWS
CONFERENCE.
DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO SAY?
>> JUST A WORD OF THANKS.
YOU SAID ABOUT 45 DAYS AGO WHEN
WE BROUGHT MANY OF THESE
RETAILERS TOGETHER WITH THESE
REMARKABLE COMMERCIAL LABS.
WE BUILD ON A PUBLIC-PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP THAT YOU FORGED
EARLY IN THE CORONAVIRUS
EPIDEMIC.
WHEN WE FIRST SAT DOWN AT YOUR
DIRECTION WITH THESE GREAT
COMMERCIAL LABS ON MARCH 4TH,
OUR COUNTRY HAD CONDUCTED
ROUGHLY 25,000 CORONAVIRUS
TESTS.
TODAY, THAT NUMBER IS
5.4 MILLION.
AND WITH THE SUPPORT OF
COMPANIES LIKE CVS HEALTH AND
WALMART, WALGREENS, TARGET, AND
OTHERS, WE ARE NOW SCALING AND
WORKING WITH GOVERNORS AS THEY
IMPLEMENT THEIR TESTING PLANS.
AND IT REALLY IS WHAT YOU SAID
EARLY ON, MR. PRESIDENT.
THIS IS THE WHOLE OF AMERICA
APPROACH.
YOU HAVE BROUGHT ALL OF
AMERICA’S BEST TOGETHER.
OUR RETAILERS, COMMERCIAL
LABORATORIES.
THE RESULTS SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES.
AS WE HEARD ON THE CALL,
GOVERNORS ARE RAPIDLY EXPANDING
TESTING ACROSS THE STATE AS THEY
MOVED TOWARD A PHASED AND
RESPONSIBLE REOPENING OF THEIR
STATE AND THIS NATION’S ECONOMY.
I’M GLAD TO BE BACK WITH THIS
GROUP, MR. PRESIDENT.
I KNOW HOW GRATEFUL YOU ARE FOR
THE COLLABORATION AROUND THIS
TABLE.
I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING HOW WE
CAN LOOK FORWARD TO BUILDING
EVEN MORE MOMENTUM IN THE
PROGRESS WE ARE MAKING AS A
NATION WORKING WITH THESE GREAT
RETAILERS AND WORKING WITH THESE
EXTRAORDINARY COMMERCIAL LABS
HAVE DONE SO MUCH FOR AMERICA IN
SUCH A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.